if she went through with the trip pelosi
wouldn't be the first sitting u.s
speaker to visit taiwan that would be my
next guest joining me now is newt
gingrich fox news contributor author of
the fantastic book defeating big
government socialism mr speaker now we
have pictures up right now of your own
trip to taiwan back in 1997.
since then it's it's quite amazing that
no house speaker has traveled there the
excuse is always
given that you know that china has
gotten more aggressive so we've got to
be careful not to provoke them
but what does that say about us
well
i have to say laura i was a little
surprised to realize i was the highest
ranking
american official ever
to visit taiwan we did so as part of a
trip the chinese communists had invited
us to shanghai and beijing we'd agreed
yes i went with a bipartisan delegation
one of the points i'd make to nancy
pelosi is very important take a
bipartisan delegation we had 11 members
including john dingell who was the
senior democrat at that time
and we said to them just before the trip
started by the way we're going to go to
taiwan they were furious
they did everything they're doing right
now they they threatened they bullied
they bluffed
and gardner peckham who was my national
security advisor i remember being near
him he's on a phone call the chinese
ambassador and he finally said look
the chinese communists are not the
travel guides for the american speaker
of the house
if you don't want him to come to china
he'll skip china and go to taiwan
well all of a sudden they said well no
no no no
i went to china now the only condition
was we had to go china
japan and then back to taiwan we
couldn't go directly from mainland
china's the communist part directly to
taiwan
the the president of taiwan met with all
of us a bipartisan delegation they were
thrilled that we were there i was really
surprised to realize that that 1997
visit was the last time that a senior
american leader had actually visited
taiwan i encouraged nancy to go
particularly now that it's public
i think it would be humiliating
and destructive if she were to back down
and i have to say having a woke defense
department that's not sure if you deal
with the american speaker go to the to
taiwan makes you wonder what they would
do in a real crisis
yeah well 800 billion dollars a year i
mean that's what their budget is right
so newt here's how the white house today
tried to explain biden's stance on this
trip watch this
you can't say whether the president
personally
would support this trip even in a
hypothetical you know i have not spoken
to him personally you've heard him i
think someone and maybe someone on your
team asked him a week ago last wednesday
about this particularly uh specifically
about the speaker's travel i'm not going
to go beyond what he said
now this is no small issue
and she's claiming that she hasn't
spoken to the president about it really
sure of course i believe that
i mean you've got a guy who has
cognitive challenges i'm not sure he
knows where taiwan is
uh
why would and his oppressed secretary
doesn't know anything so why would you
think that the woman who did not know
anything and the guy who can't remember
what it is he used to know would
actually have a conversation about a
topic that's only very very important
i i think you have to recognize
this is very simple
if speaker pelosi backs down
what the chinese communists will learn
is one more example of where american
weakness at a time when the buy
administration was defeated in
afghanistan has failed totally in
ukraine
and continues to signal its utter
weakness uh this would be i think
increasing the danger of a communist
invasion of taiwan on the other hand
if speaker pelosi decides as i hope she
will
to take a bipartisan delegation so it's
very clear to the chinese communist
whether you're democrat or you're
republican we are for
the freedom of taiwan from not being
invited i think that's important
historically
it would be amazing for her legacy i'm
not trying to give her legacy advice but
that's a separate point obviously but it
would be great for her to separate
herself from the herd mentality which
seems to be moving to protect china's
interest in the united states so i think
she's smart enough to do the right thing
i hope so newt you were the perfect
guest tonight thank you so much